we consume food to get energy and do our  day-to-day activities  some of us consume poultry which is  chicken chicken eats worms for survival  worms eat microbes from the soil and  this goes on this one single chain of  who eats whom is called the food chain a  food chain represents a simple linear  pathway through which energy and  materials are transferred from one  species to another in an ecosystem but  in reality each one of us consumes  different types of food like vegetables  grains meat and poultry each of this  food item that we consume is also  dependent on another source for its own  growth for example vegetables are  dependent on the sun for photosynthesis  etc  so itd every organism doesn't have a  single food source but multiple sources  and each source in turn has multiple  sources of food a food web is nothing  but a diagram of feeding relationships  that includes multiple intersecting food  chains